notre groupe d'amis se
connaissent depuis que nous sommes bébés
nous avons confiance
en l'histoire nous possédons cette école
il attend la lumière
elle n'est pas d'ici
hé
comment voudrais-tu venir traîner avec nous
ce soir
[Musique]
trop de manèges et de papa  jaguar
trop de mensonges blancs et
de lignes blanches enfants super riches avec rien d'autre
que des bouts enfants super riches avec
rien d'autre que de faux
amis c'est une étrangère
qui s'est retrouvée dans votre
groupe d'amis avec votre petit ami
j'ai promis de rester à l'écart de tout
drame
[Musique  ]
je t'ai manqué je sais que tu m'as manqué
gossip girl
un compte instagram anonyme qui
espionne nos étudiants
ceci juste en il y a un grand secret
parmi la classe dirigeante à constance
billard
[Musique]
pourquoi les commérages grandissent pour nous avoir
je '  Je ne sais pas seulement que
je suis influent
et que je ne peux pas me priver de ce
privilège et que le pouvoir finira toujours par l'emporter.
bon chemin de
la meilleure façon
vous